Coffee on a Tuesday in block 35,
so there's a way to use hashtags to
categorize tweets or messages so that
they show up more easily in searches,
but I don't ever use hashtags like that.
There are amazing political consequences
to Hashtags,
fast and easy ways to communicate to
find information on a particular subject
or event like a riot or a revolution,
but I don't ever use hashtags like that.
The hashtag was thriving when I came to
it.
People were already using it for all of
those democratizing reasons I just
mentioned as a way of networking or
advocating,
but the networking function of hashtags
never really interested me,
but I noticed that people were using
hashtags in other ways to to express
sarcasm or wit or inner monologue or
self deprecation and I thought I can get
into that.
The first Hashtag I ever used was on an
instagram photo I took in La.
Have a man who was dressed up as a
yellow transformer who is done with his
day just walking home from work in his
costume.
My caption was,
melancholy transformer.
Hashtag save.
So,
so at the expense of murdering comedy,
by analyzing it,
I was making a joke here about a man
whose jobs seemed to be to dress up in a
bulky transformers costume and walk
around the streets of La and he didn't
seem too happy about it.
And hashtag save yourself.
It's just a way of saying,
you can do better than this.
Just for a moment.
Let's disregard all the ridiculous
assumptions I'm making about this guy's
life who I know nothing about who very
well might love it's June,
may very well just have gotten back from
transformers.
Cope very well,
might have a perfectly normal fetish for
dressing up as bubble who may very well
be a transforming android.
Now I could've just said,
save yourself no Hashtag,
and the message I was trying to convey
about this guy's life would have gotten
across.
What I'm interested in is whether or not
the addition of a Hashtag as any
literary value to the sentiment,
and I think it does.
I was mocking,
but at the same time,
borrowing the intended function of
hashtags as a means to connect our
expression in order to add a layer of
subtext to the company instead of just
telling this guy to get a life I was
making like the Hashtag save yourself.
Grouping already existed,
that it was trending.
People were adding to it as a way to
infer that this ridiculous thing is only
one example of millions of similarly
ridiculous things,
maybe even a ridiculous thing that you
do with the Hashtag you invoke the
community even when the community isn't
there.
Of course I wasn't thinking this out as
I did it and the only way that I learned
the literary way of using hashtags is by
seeing other people do it first and
there are many other ways to use
hashtags dramatically to express self
deprecation or inner monologue for
insecurity.
I find it fascinating that we can't help
but repurpose everything we see into
stories,
even metadata,
metadata and your functions.
We will take your metadata and make it
into box.
We are an race to say the least and it's
no surprise to me that twitter caught on
like it did.
It's no surprise the effect it's already
had on the world and it's no surprise
that we figured out how to make little
messages into big messages without ever
changing the character counts.
Hey,
everyone and screen had been here.
So I wanted to let you know that we did
a story last week on lean forward about
the one year anniversary of occupy Wall
Street,
which I've put on my facebook page and
I'll put the link in the dually do.
So from now on,
that's where I'm going to put the links
to videos or stories that I do on MSNBC.
Um,
besides that chagall 52 books they did
two weeks.
Don't forget to follow me on tumblr
there.
Um,
and Hashtag goodbye.